[Music]
[Music]
it's seven o'clock welcome to a sky news
tonight special on afghanistan
after 20 years of foreign occupation the
country fell to the taliban on the 15th
of august last year now a country under
international sanctions and the strict
regime of the taliban millions of people
are going without food and medicine in a
series of special reports from
afghanistan sky news has witnessed
firsthand the suffering people are
facing under the new rule suffering that
has prompted the united nations to ask
for more than five billion dollars in
funding that is the largest ever appeal
for a single country for humanitarian
assistance this is a sky news tonight
special afghanistan the fight for
survival
in fact it is a
i think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban
this is absolutely awful
before the explosion we just decided to
go back home because we couldn't make
way to go inside the airport
[Music]
a dark future looking for us we are lost
our jobs we all lost our dreams
the suffering on the ground is
absolutely palpable
the international community cannot
condemn the afghan people to collective
punishment and starvation because they
failed in their mission
this man tells us we've no choice we've
already sold our kidneys now we've got
to sell our children we are nervous
about
for our security our family we want to
live in safe situation in our country
but this is not possible
[Music]
a very good evening in tonight's special
we'll be getting the thoughts of our
experts about the humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan
as well as getting their response to a
series of reports delivered by our
special correspondent alex crawford who
joins me now live from the capital kabul
and alex of course you've been
witnessing and describing for us some
some truly desperate scenes give us your
impression of how it is on the ground
well
it actually is pretty horrendous there
are images that no one should have to
witness and definitely no one should
have to live through
images that we can't even bring to you
because it's before the watershed of
babies who frozen to death and they're
not isolated cases they very much are
not isolated cases on one morning there
was a mother who who'd lost two of her
babies frozen wandering around kabul
market holding them and crying this is a
very regular regular event there are
literally millions millions of people
who are going to bed hungry tonight who
don't have enough food and who are
resorting to ever more desperate
measures
just to survive we saw literally scores
and scores of men who'd sold body parts
now
the kidney organ trade is quite a
lucrative one it always has been for
many years especially near the iranian
border but the figures that we're seeing
on the ground the anecdotal evidence
that we're getting is that it has spiked
enormously over the past six months so
now it's not just men who are selling
their body cut parts it's women too and
i was particularly shocked by that
because these women were so young they
were 17 years old 18 19 20. they'd
already sold their kidneys they didn't
have anything else to sell the next
thing that was in line was one of one of
their children
they'd often lost babies and toddlers
already through starvation or through
illness brought on by being malnourished
and now they were thinking the the very
worst as far as the mother's concern
trying to sell off a child to try and
keep the others alive from many families
many many families say that was the only
option that if they're going to keep the
others alive they've got to do this
there is people begging everywhere you
go you know if you're in a car if you're
in a street if you're walking
almost every single town village that we
went to people
saw us as foreigners and immediately
came up and those there's children tiny
children begging there's women in burkas
offering sitting on the streets offering
to sell their children there are babies
in burns units in herat who
are being sent home prospect to being
sent home to die because their parents
and the hospital cannot afford to pay
for the bandages to keep them alive so a
very desperate situation here on the
ground dermot
and alex one of the taliban they of
course say they've changed from the last
time they ruled afghanistan that they're
allowing humanitarian aid through their
they're not hunting members of the
regime that they're promoting women and
allowing them to access education is
that the reality
i think we have to take everything that
they say with a huge piece of pinch of
salt and i say that from direct evidence
we have we have spoken to a number of
female activists and their families
their relatives who have been raided who
protested about the drawing back of
women's rights and who were then their
homes were raged and they were actually
arrested and they have disappeared when
i put it to senior taliban spokesman
they flatly denied it absolutely flatly
denied it even though we have multiple
eyewitnesses
neighbors who can speak at length about
seeing taliban fighters coming to the
house raiding and picking them up
aid on the ground even if there is some
aid it is not nearly enough now the
taliban are running on empty they have
no money many of them are under
international sanctions there is no
money here it is a completely empty cash
economy which means that the taliban for
instance are starting a a work for aid
program so they will give you aid if you
come to work they're paying state
employees because that food aid which
the country depended on so much nearly
six months ago has just disappeared that
means civil servants health workers
nurses teachers engineers are all not
being paid so the country is definitely
definitely suffering have the taliban
changed i would say absolutely
categorically they have not changed
enough for certain because the women
rights have been eroded human rights
have been eroded people are being hunted
down because they worked for former the
former government because they worked
with the former uh foreign troops who
were based here and this is all despite
promises from the taliban who promised
that there would be an amnesty and there
would be
equal rights for women alex for the time
being thanks for that we'll speak a lot
more a bit later on in this special and
uh just to let you know earlier today we
put some of those issues to the
taliban's official spokesperson and the
united nations humanitarian coordinator
in kabul and we'll bring you those
interviews throughout this special but
first i want to get the initial thoughts
of our esteemed panel i'm joined now by
sir mark locock who's the former
undersecretary general for humanitarian
affairs and emergency relief coordinator
we've got shukria baraksai who's a
former afghan politician and ambassador
to norway who escaped from afghanistan
to the united kingdom and rory stewart
joins us formerly secretary of state for
international development a very good
evening to you all if i could start with
you sir mark i mean quite clearly
afghanistan is facing the abbess
how
did we get to this point
yeah it is facing the abyss
below which is mass starvation of the
whole population
and that's
arisen because starting from a very
fragile position
six months ago
um the effect of the collapse of the
economy
produced largely by decisions taken by
western countries when the taliban
came under control has been to rob
people of their incomes it's been to
rob the country of the ability to import
food so people are starving and
desperate and that is why they are
selling their kidneys and their other
body parts and that is why they're
selling their children so you can trace
back to
the immediate aftermath of the taliban
takeover
the
the direct causes of the abyss we're
seeing now and indeed many people
including people you have on the program
tonight forecast
that unless different things happened we
would be seeing this kind of situation
now
and rory stewart your your thoughts uh
on just that that history recent history
the the 20 years of uh western rural
western occupation whatever you want to
call it i mean it's hundreds of billions
trillions of dollars
spent it just wasn't meant to be like
this
it's it's heartbreaking i think it's
heartbreaking in every way it's
heartbreaking because in effect
we the united states the united kingdom
and the nato allies caused this
we built a huge afghan state
and we made an afghan budget with 70
percent dependence on international aid
so that teachers couldn't be paid
without international aid health work
couldn't keep going with that
internationally supported the entire
economy and then we turned around on a
dime left in august abandoned the
country completely have now frozen the
bank accounts cut off all the support to
those teachers salaries
and i feel that although the politicians
are often saying the reason they're not
providing the aid more flexibly is
they're worried the taliban are going to
steal it
there isn't really any evidence for that
at all there's not evidence the taliban
is stealing aid the real reason we're
not providing it is that the west feels
humiliated and bitter
because it was defeated
just give us your sense of the quite
clearly the
the missed opportunities the legions
have missed opportunities over the past
two decades or so
there was a lot of opportunities what's
been missed but unfortunately today's
situation is not the fault of afghans
first of all we should be clear about
this one and of course the starvation of
a nation shouldn't be a type of
punishment that the international
community in including the taliban would
like to seen it i think this is the
catastrophe this is the humanitarian
crisis which is immediate need to be
assistance and i hope the united nations
should reach out as soon as possible to
put in dot for that catastrophe at the
moment otherwise this humanitarian
crisis will may deliver a lot of that
impact not only the security in the
world but of course probably in the 21st
century the most horrific humanitarian
crisis in the history well do stay with
us because that is the very issue we are
going to address right now head on
because when kabul fell to the taliban
the un promised not to leave the people
of afghanistan behind that from the u.n
secretary general well a bit earlier i
put just that to dr ramiz al-abbarov the
humanitarian coordinator at the united
nations with special responsibility for
afghanistan based in the capital kabul
we did what we said we will do
we stayed and we delivered it's
been a very very difficult
several months
we've been working in getting aid to the
country
uh we managed towards the end of the
year to
scale up uh to almost 18 million people
with food and
more than 8 million people were reached
just since the august and
i'm very proud of what my
teams here in afghanistan and all of us
as the un were able to do
and you need continuing support you need
more the the estimate coming from the
u.n is immediately four and a half
billion dollars
absolutely this is a huge humanitarian
catastrophe you have half of the country
uh in
acute
need of food medicines and essential
supplies
we also need to support and maintain
basic human needs of this country and
that means access to essential social
services such as health
supply water electricity and obviously
uh as as we're crossing a very harsh
winter month
all of it is absolutely critical for
survival of the people when it comes to
the distribution of this much needed aid
on such a large scale
tell me about the un's cooperation or
lack of it with the taliban because you
know the taliban have recently asked for
a greater role they want to work
alongside the un coordinating aid
is that possible would that make it more
efficient
so uh taliban just as any other
recipient of the humanitarian aids
like de facto authorities in the areas
where there are recipients of the
humanitarian aid i mean uh they can
highlight to us that okay certain areas
they're vulnerable people and so far we
would like to assess uh these areas
independently but uh they do not
participate in a distribution we do not
provide any aid into the hands of
taliban and they are not present at the
places and the times and they do it what
happens
if the world doesn't get its act
together if that four and a half billion
and more isn't found and distributed
just give us your your eyewitness sense
of just how bad things are
it is bad
imagine you're traveling through the
rural areas and you're going to
hospitals where you see five six
children on one bed freezing on the bed
because there is no
uh there is no heating and you are
looking at their eyes and there is no
sufficient amount of medicine or
anything to treat them and between the
freezing temperature and and the measles
uh which is hitting them hard
malnourished children
the outcomes don't look good
out of 10 women which are in need of
cesarean section
today in afghanistan only three will be
able to get it
what that means for seven women who will
not get cesarean section
uh i i don't think i need to explain
what that means the the the human face
of it what is staring at us is extremely
poor
rural underdeveloped afghanistan
with thousands and hundreds of thousands
and millions of people
not able to have a basic
very basic mill
and very basic human dignity setting
with some some some warmth and and some
protection
from the un in kabul well throughout
this special program we'll be bringing
you some of the reports that alex
crawford and her team have delivered
from afghanistan in the past few weeks
the first clip we can show the desperate
situation of people living in a village
near where people as alex alluded to are
selling their kidneys to pay for food
and fighting over aid
the aid is fought over what's here is
far outweighed by the huge need
it's really very hard in afghanistan
right now she says and there are too
many people like me who don't have a
husband or a father to support them
[Music]
for women who aren't allowed to work
under the taliban and aren't even
allowed to complain about that it's
misery on misery
she's crying telling us her bag of flour
has been stolen
i don't know what i'm going to do she
says
foreign aids not feeding into the
country while politicians wrestle over
dealing with the taliban regime holding
power because they're holding the guns
let's get back to the thoughts of our
panel about the aid situation and shukri
barak sai as you said earlier it's not
the afghan people who are responsible
for this dire situation let me ask you
then
about the taliban are they the problem
or perhaps even part of the solution
there's no doubt to
to seeing taliban as a problem
because the lack of responsibility from
the taliban side and the lack of
experience
as a
ruling government
or government is also one of the issues
taliban are just a militant group but
they can change this de facto government
can change their face from the problem
to be a part of solution if they are
willing to cooperate with international
organization
if they trying to gain
a local
legitimacy or internal legitimacy inside
of afghanistan or if they are
accepting the very basic fundamental
human rights
and
in civil rights in afghanistan if
they're going to
change their uh or fulfill their
promises that they made in doha i think
that will change the the the taliban
from a problem to be a solution but to
be honest
what is very very important
in the last six months everybody was
been aware that the humanitarian crisis
is on the way
when united nations appeal for foreign
aid i think before december
more than one billion dollar was been
collected
the question is
why the aid is not reaching out
immediately and necessary to the people
i believe politicizing aid either by
donors or taliban that's not the that's
not the solution that we should think
about them
you know for for the humanitarian aid we
should be very fast very
quick and very sufficient to deliver
rather than putting conditions from both
parties and that those conditions will
may not be solved that's why a part of
those humanitarian aids that need to be
delivered it was been hanging in the
middle and that's why people are
starving now i think
before we understood we everybody was
learned and aware that um
the crisis were on the way it's not just
only humanitarian crisis it's a
political crisis economical crisis and
all other crises including the lack of
human dignity which is taliban are not
really willing to accept it is a part of
the crisis but who's trying to solve the
crisis without thinking
yeah i mean i'm sorry i just want to get
the the thoughts of the gentleman in the
in the discussion because they're
they're nodding along um with that
analysis and uh rory stewart and i mean
basically is the situation just so dire
that talking about the the fineries of
um the political settlement and uh who
does this that and the other doesn't
really matter at this point it's getting
this much-needed aid to the people that
need it before they die
absolutely look political settlement
with the taliban is very important but
it's a long-term painful patient
business
and there are nine million people on the
edge of starvation
it is unbelievable that we're not doing
more to help the united states alone was
spending a hundred billion dollars a
year in afghanistan at the peak of its
presence there
we're asking for only five percent of
that money
and the security actually at the moment
in afghanistan is better than it has
been paradoxically for nearly 15 years
there is absolutely no reason why we
could not have development workers on
the ground and the reason this money
isn't being collected and the reason it
isn't being spent is that the
governments are not putting their energy
behind it people are tied up in
bureaucratic regulations
incredible numbers of restrictions which
are making ngos very nervous about work
they do on the ground not nervous the
taliban but nervous that they're going
to get in trouble from un sanctions will
get in trouble from u.s treasury rules
and it is extraordinary at the very
moment where assistance needs to be
coming
many of these governments are actually
cutting the support to ngos that have
been operating on the ground for 15 or
20 years
well let's just i'm going to bring in
some mark lowcock on that let's just uh
take our viewers through just the scale
of some of the relief that's needed what
aid is required in afghanistan the
united nations as you may have heard
already says 4.4 billion dollars are
needed immediately for the afghanistan
humanitarian response plan alone to pay
direct as rory stuart was saying there
to health workers and others not the de
facto authorities with an extra
623 million to support refugees and host
communities in five neighboring
countries for the afghanistan situation
regional refugee response plan now the
uk has pledged just under 100 million
pounds of emergency aid for vital
humanitarian assistance in afghanistan
this winter 286 million pounds to be
committed in total this financial year
uh and so
eye-watering amounts and needed as soon
as possible as we've been been saying
just talk us through though the role of
sanctions in making this situation worse
yes the sanctions is what's collapsed
the economy basically and the sanctions
include the slashing of the eight
um the
it's really not rocket science to turn
this problem round quickly all that's
needed is people who promise the money
including the british government
to write the ch checks quickly that will
enable the un to scale up and then
afghanistan's own resources money held
by individuals which is blocked in
foreign accounts money owed to
afghanistan by the world bank
afghanistan's foreign exchange reserves
those things need to be unlocked as well
alongside
the
funding of the un appeal
um all of those things have been done in
other circumstances in other countries
so
nobody can pretend they don't know
what's needed no one can pretend they
don't know what the source of the
problem is
i think what's needed is a
recognition that
the country's now on the abyss
if you don't act now you are going to be
staring in the face of mass starvation
and that will be on the shoulders of
decision makers who have all the
information on what needs to be done
well much more to come thank you for the
time being for that because i want to
take you through now some of the
response from the taliban because
earlier today i spoke to sahil shaheen
he's the taliban's official spokesperson
and i asked him directly about the
humanitarian crisis in his country and
if the taliban was responsible
it is the result of the sanction
imposed
on afghanistan
so
it
returns to those who have imposed the
sanctions
which have resulted
in
a humanitarian crisis in afghanistan
on our behalf during the last
six months
we have done
what we have
we had in our
capacity
uh to do for for the people of
afghanistan
and we
will continue to do so in order to
alleviate
the
suffering
the problems of the people of
afghanistan but it needs the
international community
to cooperate with us
not to punish the people of afghanistan
by imposing
unjustified
sanctions and the country but to have
those sanctions relieved to gain that
recognition you say you want the
international community uh requires you
to do some pretty simple things that
you've said you will do but you haven't
done yet
guarantee the rights of women of
minorities open up education to all uh
so many simple things why haven't they
happened yet
those things have
happened
because
the demand of the people of afghanistan
we have no problem with women
having access to work and
through education
a few days ago
our minister of higher education
announced
opening of all universities
to both
male and female
students
so that
issue is resolved
only
in some places
there may be
the issue of
capacity like not having
enough number of
lecturers and professors and like uh not
having
money
to
carry out our programs it is
the obligation of the international
community
to
provide us
cooperate us financially
in order to
achieve that
goal
that's the taliban's interpretation
we'll get more from my interview with
sahil shaheen a bit later in this
special program but first let's see uh
more of what our special correspondent
alex crawford has witnessed during her
time in the country how some families in
bardees province are selling their young
daughters into marriage to raise money
five years old
six years old these are girls already
sold into marriage many too young to
even know their own ages
eight years they're often prompted by
their guardians
six years the husbands they'll go to are
a decade or more older the last to talk
is five years old
the youngest in her father's arms is a
seven month baby given in lieu of
medical bills
the girls have no say
this in one of afghanistan's poorest
villages
and the deprivation here means girls are
being sold into marriage earlier and
more often
there's not enough room in the tent for
all the parents who want to show us
their young daughters they've sold
we don't want to sell them she says but
we're poor and we have to eat
desperate well let's return to our panel
now and uh shukri barak zai
it is crucial in terms of how we
deal with the taliban how they
treat women and young girls
of course
i think just the interview and the
report of alex can give a
proper picture what's going on in
afghanistan
denying from taliban side it's not
something new they always been keeping
denying they're taking hostage women's
day denied they are
shooting on a woman on the streets
particularly the protester they denied
they didn't accept they didn't take
responsibility even when it comes to the
poverty or delivering services they are
not taking responsibility but when it
comes to the women's and when i when i
saw that video it's it's really
it's it's very heartbroken because i was
been working for 24 years and i've been
standing against the child marriages
forced marriages
and and and that's i think something
which is
it's not only afghan and i think this is
the international community should take
action this is not the time that we
should be just witness seeing what's
going on
and showing sympathy it's need more
further steps we need to hold taliban
accountable for the situation
circumstances that today the people of
afghanistan are facing it's not the
fault of afghan people it's the fault of
us even most of the time i'm blaming
myself because i rely on those partners
which is they betray us
so this is the time we should put again
our effort together to at least gain
back one thing with the name of humanity
when it comes to the taliban and their
rules of course they've never been kind
with the women and they
their policy always been so harsh before
sohail shain says that they offered and
they announced opening of the university
but today in the social media they
didn't let women to get into those
universities because they asked them to
full cover
their face from head to toes and this is
something even not islamic action as the
taliban are measuring today and they are
forcing on the women in afghanistan i
think the women's issue with the taliban
is a historical issue between women and
taliban and we will not give up it's
it's time the taliban should fix their
own problems rather than women in
afghanistan rory stewart share with us
your
insight into the nature of the taliban
clearly there's a center and you know
sahil shaheen
saying those things and maybe he he
believes them ultimately and you know
the united states negotiates with that
center we see it ourselves but just the
nature of afghanistan and the nature of
the taliban and its representatives its
members spread out over such a vast area
over so many provinces
is it possible to understand it as a
single entity
of course it's very fragmented and it's
very thin
it's not really a governing apparatus
this was a resistance movement that
fought for 20 years to try to destroy
almost everything that
the afghan government backed by the
international community tried to create
and these are people driven by a very
very strange religious vision which is
not really an islamic mission it's a
very peculiar
taliban vision which comes from
communities in southern afghanistan and
they are of course
all those things that supreme barracks i
have said they have
very repressive views towards women
they are very fragmented there are at
least three major groups in the taliban
they have very complicated relationships
with terrorist groups and they've
actually pulled
some very major terrorist figures into
their government
but and this is a very difficult thing
to say
we cannot use that as an excuse to
starve the afghan people
there is no point going on television
and attacking the taliban for
their imposing restrictions on women
going to school
women can go to school in afghanistan
but in restricted ways but we cannot
complain about that if we are refusing
to provide any of the money that pays
teachers salaries not a single teacher
has been paid in afghanistan since
august
so mark be interesting to get your
thoughts down on how we how he nuanced
that how you keep the pressure on the
taliban but as rory stewart as you've
all been saying how that money flows as
quickly as possible to these desperate
people
well
the un for the last 20 years with ngos
and others has been providing assistance
to deal with humanitarian problems month
after month year after year
with the acquiescence and tolerance of
the
taliban in areas they
controlled as renis alpha off said
earlier in your program
agencies know how to do this the taliban
have got used to not interfering with
the distribution of food and other
assistance that the central immediate
problem right now is is because of the
economic measures and the sanctions the
agencies don't have the money to reach
all the people who are starving i think
there's need for some kind of
international conference now at the
leader level uh to really get a grip of
this because time is running out to deal
with this problem some things can be
dealt with in the medium term like some
kind of new
polity or engagement with the taliban
which every company in the world is
going to need to work out a solution for
but the immediate problem is to avoid
you know the moral repugnant outcome of
a population being starved as a result
of the economic measures because people
don't like a regime that the population
itself had no choice over
well do stay with us we're going to take
a break but just before we do that um
let's leave you with uh some more stark
figures all of them stark aren't they uh
because uh this is the scale of the
problem there out of a population of
just over 30 million people in
afghanistan according to the world food
programme over two-thirds 22.8 million
people are facing severe hunger there
nearly 9 million 8.7 are on the brink
the very brink of starvation itself and
10 million children are in need of
humanitarian aid that's figures
that unicef have released much more to
discuss then on that you're watching a
special sky news tonight programme
afghanistan the fight for survival
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to our special program
afghanistan the fight for survival
well there have been many reports from
the country people who were against the
taliban who have helped foreign forces
going missing or being hunted by the
taliban regime and sky's alex crawford
visited a jail which suggests that the
taliban has been carrying out a vendetta
against employees of the country's
former government
many have been here for months already
and they're accused of stealing adultery
not paying debts and fraud
the prison governor is behind us so they
answer our questions cautiously
but one with a fresh injury tells us
many are employees of the former
government
he says they've been put here without
proof or trials the governor tells our
interpreter not to translate before
we're moved on
we're being told not to ask them any
more questions
and uh
to leave
the taliban promised an amnesty for
those who worked with the foreign troops
or the government they toppled
but our evidence suggests this is not
being applied
instead there are widespread claims that
those now behind bars
are only there because of multiple
vendettas being carried out instead
the governor used to run a secret
taliban prison before they came to power
his office may be different but human
rights groups are worried he's using the
same old techniques
he and his men are implicated in the
disappearance of the female governor of
the women's prison
alia razizi disappeared more than four
months ago and she's not been seen since
and the governor admits to us he
personally rang her to come to work
he says he's no idea where she is but
insists she was corrupt and she's
probably claimed asylum elsewhere
let's bring our panel back in sir mark
lowcock former
under secretary general for humanitarian
affairs and emergency relief coordinator
we've got shakria baraksai who's a
former afghan politician and ambassador
to norway who escaped from afghanistan
to the uk and rory stewart's the former
secretary of state for international
developments well let's get on to that
very subject uh sir mark and
the people there that
alex was reporting on alex crawford was
reporting on are some of the people to
whom
the west are with duty of care a duty of
protection to and that's down to this
botched withdrawal how do we get it so
badly wrong
well i'm sure that historians will study
that for a long time and the lessons
need to be
learned from it i think that the
you know it's highly credible actually
the messages that alex was conveying in
that last report there the taliban is
fragmented as laurie stewart said
earlier there's not a very good command
control system it may well be that some
things are happening that the leadership
might not want to be happening but
there's a history of very bad things
happening the issue really is is that
justification
for the mass starvation of the whole
population and clearly it's not so we
need to separate out
the needs of the total population from
the need to engage with the taliban to
try to get them over the medium and
longer term to behave in a more
acceptable way
shakira barack says as a former member
of the the previous administration would
that be happening to you do you think if
you'd remain
well lots of things happen to me but um
it's it's hard to remain dear because um
when
you before you give some figures let me
let me tell you one thing i think the
most important thing afghanistan need 35
million
people needs
justice
the rights of freedom and dignity
i think in the absence of these three
it's hard to to take care of starvation
or humanitarian crisis or even to talk
about those people which is they work
with foreigners as an interpretator or
as others because the lack of justice is
been badly
damaging the afghan people and
population and their different name and
the different circumstances so because
we are it's not only women are being a
victim of taliban policies it's also
people that they work with foreign
troops it's it's also not a very nice to
see your ex-colleagues was being left
behind just because of bureaucracy they
couldn't reach and they couldn't get to
safe places and this is
for the taliban that's more than enough
to punish and shoot someone because they
work with foreign
troops or they work with the
former government of afghanistan and i
think that's such a kind of behavior
it's uh it's it's a very um
not a top even you cannot imagine how
difficult it is to to deal with the
taliban and and to accept them under one
roof but what is the most important one
of course to taking care and tackling
disturbation but besides of everything
freeing and releasing people 35 million
with the dignity and
um with the humanity with with the
freedom that's that's also very very
important which is no one trying to even
think about it i feel bad when today the
sir david richard was asking for a kind
of
negotiation and legitimacy for the
taliban nobody asked him okay sir why
you fight against them when you were
leading
the coalition force in afghanistan if
they were such a deer today okay why
yesterday
i i just want to get on to rory stewart
there in this issue of the duty of care
and you know there's awful scenes we saw
uh back in august of people clinging to
aircraft been blown up outside the
airport just just terrible scenes and
that duty of care you know let's just
concentrate on the united kingdom the
united kingdom said at the time those of
you who can't get out make your way to a
third country and we will facilitate you
coming to the uk is there any evidence
of that actually happening
no
it's a terrible betrayal the uk
government made some big announcements
in august
committed to take 25 000 afghans said it
was going to focus on afghans who are
particularly the kind of people who are
vulnerable to the sort of images you
were showing in other words
female judges for example who prosecuted
the taliban or human rights campaigners
but in fact this scheme hasn't really
come into existence at all
and it's very very difficult for afghans
to cross into neighbouring countries and
register with unhcr which is what the
british government said they needed to
do
and the british government is part of a
complete failure which i'm afraid
extends to most of our european navals
and allies too
to actually take serious numbers of
afghans as refugees from that country we
could do it very easily
there are lots of human rights
organizations ngos on the ground that
could help to process afghans who are
genuinely in need
who are genuinely if they stay there
much longer are going to find themselves
at risk of being killed there is a
window for them to get out there's a
window for many of these people to be
able to get out and we are not providing
it yet again we are betraying afghans
and it's extraordinary for 20 years
the international community kept saying
that we were committed to afghanistan
that afghanistan was vital to our
security that we were going to invest
all these lives and money and then in an
instant in the middle of august we
decided to forget all about it and all
those responsibilities okay i want to
get uh the taliban response now uh from
sehail shaheen the official spokesperson
for the taliban who spoke to me earlier
and i asked him about this issue of
activists disappearing
sky news has been reporting on an
increasing number of young female
activists disappearing being kidnapped
with eyewitnesses
saying that this is being done by the
taliban no these are allegations i have
heard this allegation but when i
contacted the intelligence department
and the ministry of interior
they told me that no one from
their departments has
become any activist
so in afghanistan there are people in
order to make uh
cases of asylum and to resettle abroad
they are making such a fake cases
shaheen there now you're watching uh sky
news tonight special program about
afghanistan the fight for survival stay
with us
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yeah
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
the united states would become hooked
[Music]
the enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network
not just in iraq and syria but across
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to this special program
afghanistan the fight for survival well
winters in afghanistan can of course be
tough at the best of times but this year
there's also a measles outbreak and a
shortage of medicines which really does
mean it's a struggle for the weakest to
stay alive here's more of alex
crawford's reporting from bad geese
the women of badgis queue for hours for
free paracetamol for the sick
in afghanistan's most deprived province
nothing comes easy and everything's
scarce
they're cramming babies onto beds in the
province's main hospital in some wards
it's standing room only
a measles outbreak is ripping through
them in the tiny who have already poor
immunity measles can be a death sentence
let's go back to our panel on that uh
and uh rory stewart here's another
illustration if we needed one of the
scale and range
of this crisis and is it reaching the
point where let me read you the words of
general dave richards former chief of
the defense staff
of course saying we're going to end up
recognizing the taliban government so
i'd better do it sooner rather than
later to begin alleviating situations
like that which of course can can spread
and have spread beyond afghanistan's
borders already
i think we need to separate off
the
leverage and the influence we want to
have on the taliban in the future
which may mean holding back some
diplomatic recognition holding back big
investment projects for the future
but we need to provide immediately
generously quickly
humanitarian and development support to
stop people from starving and to do that
we need to engage with the taliban now
that may not be the same as full
diplomatic recognition but that
definitely means
that we need to have the confidence to
provide the money to get the health care
system going again get those teachers
salaries paid get development programs
going
the truth of the matter is the afghan
people did not choose the taliban
there's no evidence that the taliban is
stealing aid money and we shouldn't be
sacrificing millions of afghan lives in
some ludicrous idea that by doing so
we're going to change the taliban's
behavior
sir mark briefly if you both would that
very question time to recognize the
taliban shakri baraksi
not at all
i do believe this is the time to
concentrate and focus more about
delivering very sufficiently
humanitarian aid and plus they're in
afghanistan inside the 5000 is a huge
potential of non-governmental
organization they work in the entire 20
years they are operating much better
than taliban de facto government we
should invest on them and we should ask
for them and of course we should also
give a chance for women to be employees
on those non-governmental organizations
and that will may be a part of solution
so mike we're going to do it sooner or
later why not do it now this recognition
the immediate issue isn't recognition of
the taliban it's not going to happen
even if it did it wouldn't feed a
starving child the immediate issue is to
avoid a
massive humanitarian tragedy involving
the loss of millions of lives and all of
the other destabilization that will go
with it the supercharging of the opium
and heroin economy a big exodus of
people who will flood across the border
there's already 5 000 a day going across
into iran and the empowering and giving
sucker to extremist groups like the
islamic state franchise who are even
more brutal and unacceptable than the
taliban so
the the international community need to
seize their responsibilities and they
need to do it now
well listen thank you all so much for
your uh erudites and insightful thoughts
about low cost shakira baraksai and rory
stewart very good talking to you all
thank you so much for joining us on this
special program and throughout it we
have of course been talking about the
issues about what the future looks like
for afghanistan well i put that to sahel
shaheen the taliban's official spokesman
and what happens if the taliban
leadership do what the international
community requires and continues to
develop
an inclusive a diverse leadership there
are those within the taliban movement
who don't we know that you know that who
don't want to see that happen they want
the taliban to to rule as they did in
the last century in the 1990s and early
2000s could the taliban fall apart turn
in on itself be subject as it is already
to attacks from islamic state groups
first of all i want to
to assure you and all
that we are committed to gohan agreement
and based on that agreement uh we are
not allowing anyone any entity group to
use the soil of afghanistan against
other countries it is our policy and
commitment
we do not have any foreign agenda
what we have
is to focus on the reconstruction
of afghanistan and for that we
want to have cooperation with other
people we pay
the way and facilitate investment of
other countries
in afghanistan in our huge natural
resources to come here because that will
be beneficial for all sides and also
will uh create jobs for the people of
afghanistan will also
help contribute to security uh in the
country and security stability in
afghanistan means security stability uh
the taliban's official spokesman well
let's go back to our special
correspondent uh alex crawford lifers in
kabul and uh alex listening to what
we've heard in this hour things are
clearly moving in part due to
reporting such as your own but are they
moving fast enough
i definitely think they're definitely
not moving fast enough we're seeing
people children families men women
health workers teachers
suffering dying
every day all day now here on the ground
in afghanistan and the country
is has got an economy that is not
functioning they're not doing trade with
anyone around the world they're not
doing there's no political discourse
between anyone around the world so the
people on the ground are very very much
being hit and
there isn't time for them they're
already suffering they don't think
there's an impending humanitarian
disaster it is actually here right now
and they're going through it some of
them are dying quickly others are dying
a much more slow starvation death but
the end result at the moment is that
something has got to give and if it
doesn't give there's going to be many
many more people dying and suffering
so
even a sliver of optimism alex
i don't think so right now there is very
much no optimism right now there has to
be some giving and the taliban the
senior taliban spokesman i spoke to has
said very much that they are here to
stay they're not going anywhere so
they've offered out a hand of friendship
they want another one back and somehow
they've got to meet in the middle to
stop thousands of people dying alex
thank you so much and thank you for your
remarkable reporting alex crawford there
live for us in kabul thanks to her and
the team and afghanistan and to our
panels
shapira
and rory stewart and to you for watching
[Music]